LELAND: WELCOME BACK.
THERE’S BEEN A MISTAKE IN
TRANSPORTING PATIENTS TO THE
USNS COMFORT THAT’S DOCKED IN
NEW YORK AND, THEREFORE, THERE
ARE NOW CORONAVIRUS CASES THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT ONTO THAT
HOSPITAL SHIP.
LUCAS TOMLINSON BROKE THE STORY
AND PICKS UP OUR COVERAGE.
>> Reporter: I’M TOLD THE
NUMBER OF CASES BROUGHT ONBOARD
THE SHIP WAS LESS THAN FIVE.
THE NAVY SAYS THIS IS PROOF THE
PROTOCOLS IT PUT IN PLACE ARE
WORKING.
THE NAVY SAID, QUOTE: WHILE
ADMITTING PATIENTS WHO WERE
TRANSFERRED TO USNS COMFORT FOR
TREATMENT, A FEW PATIENTS TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID-19.
THE COMFORT HAS INFECTION
CONTROL PROCEDURES THAT ARE
FOLLOWED JUST LIKE HOSPITALS
ASSURE OUR MEDICAL EXPERTS WERE
WELL PREPARED FOR CASES LIKE
THIS AND HAVE TAKEN THE
APPROPRIATE PRECAUTIONARY
MEASURES.
THE PATIENTS WERE ISOLATED AND
RECEIVED CARE ABOARD THE SHIP
WHILE WORKING TO TRANSFER
PATIENTS TO THE JAVITS FEDERAL
MEDICAL STATION WHICH IS
TREATING COVID-19 PATIENTS.
THE COMFORT IS CAPABLE OF
CONTAINING ITS MISSION.
ABOUT A DOZEN PATIENTS WERE
TRANSFERRED TO THE HOSPITAL SHIP
COMFORT FRIDAY ONE DAY AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP APPROVED NEW
YORK GOVERNOR CUOMO’S REQUEST TO
HAVE COVID PATIENTS TREATED AT
THE JAVITS CENTER.
ALL THE NON-COVID PATIENTS WERE
THEN TRANSFERRED TO THE HOSPITAL
SHUT UP A SHORT DISTANCE -- SHIP
A SHORT DISTANCE AWAY.
IT WAS TO RELIEVE THE BURDEN ON
HOSPITALS BY TAKING THE ONLY
TRAUMA PATIENTS, NOT COVID
PATIENTS, SO LOCAL HOSPITALS
COULD FOCUS ON THE VIRUS, BUT
HALF OF PEOPLE NOW SHOW NEW
SYMPTOMS ACCORDING TO THE LATEST
DATA.
COMFORT HAS BEEN MOOREDDED ON
MANHATTAN’S WEST SIDE SINCE
ARRIVING MONDAY.
THAT POLICY OF TREATING ONLY
NON-COVID PATIENTS ONBOARD MIGHT
CHANGE.
>> WE’RE REASSESSING THAT NOW,
AND THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE IS
MAKING A RISK ASSESSMENT TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT WE
SHOULD RELIEVE SOME OF THE LOCAL
HOSPITALS.
>> Reporter: THAT DECISION’S